au festival de Salon de Provence une
rockstar une vedette du rock dur Nina
Haen invité de ce festival Nina Haen fut
la grande inspiratrice du mouvement pink
allemand de ces 5 dernières années on
l'attendait avec curiosité elle n'avait
pas fait de scène depuis près d'un an
reportage à Salon de Provence de Pascal
Deschamp et
Bernard onait prévenu Nina ha n'est plus
ce qu'elle était derrière les
maquillages et les déguisements quelque
chose aurait changé
[Musique]
a 31 ans n reste une bête de SC pourant
celle qui il y a ansait tout avant tout
le monde cherche plus à provoquer un
reette de touteç la provocation c'est
comme l'enfer ce sont les autres qui
la la provocation je sais pas ce que je
fais les choses d'intin c'est un besoin
vital pour
moi
mais je ne sais pas ce qu' la
provocation je ne me pose jamais de
question sur ceci ou
cela ça sort parce que ça a besoin de
sortir ça un sens au moment où je le
fais je ne demande pas pourquoi j'agis
un
tout reste le spectacle brillant coupant
comme le diamant et un public m d'anci
et de nouveauxans pour est avant une des
plus grand chante
de
em de l'opé mais plus plus
syp bien c'est chanteuse
[Musique]
de un truc du passé l'avenir je le vois
sans argent sans centrale nucléaire
paradis sur la terre vous savez pourquoi
j'aime faire des concerts parce que
j'aime la scène pour jouer pour danser
et peut-être aussi pour communier avec
le
public c'est un moment où on peut vivre
des choses
différentes vivre une sorte d'extase
atteindre d'autres réalités tous
ensemble
[Musique]
n pourendant l'argent le nucléaire n
citant Jim Morrison Jimmy Hendri ou
James de entre de chansons et si tout
cela ne suffisait plus à incarner le
malaise d'une
[Musique]
génération